hi guys I'm Greg I'm John so there's
news here that has dropped this week
that people have been asking me to
comment all week but because I've been
moving and I'm asked to set up this set
today in the camera and [ __ ] on the
internet so i could talk about this oh
boy this is the news that i think is
specifically fine tuned out of all like
reaction channels or whatever people
have come to me to tell me that i should
talk about this i had been just setting
this [ __ ] for years and he's
finally on the comeback give Batman a
chance Mel Gibson is in talks to
possibly direct Suicide Squad to oh boy
I feel like Mel Gibson could definitely
do this movie all right I know I haven't
talked with anyone about this I haven't
had a single conversation with John and
I barely even thought about the reason
why I prefer and when I heard I was like
yeah he could do it if you look at all
the films Mel Gibson has directed yeah
all right now they tend to be historical
drama first up dan is the pool is wider
world did a brave heart you know he did
apocalypto he did Passion of the Christ
and he comes out hacks all rich Irish
man but this guy also is great in way
does acting he's good in the modern day
greedy antihero roles yeah he's a
capable of standing out in any kind of
movie whether it's machete killed or
expendable yet even though it's directed
a modern-day movie that's like crime
grid and stuff I feel like Mel Gibson
definitely understands characters like
that his movies are so varied that I
feel like he knows how and none of his
directorial movies have been met with
just you know even the debatable ones
like well it sure is immersive so I
think he can crack something like
whatever city so now it's called a
difference Ernest its way out of his
room it's so unlike anything he's ever
had to tackle before but that's a great
idea I think for DC to do that because
while you're hiring a villain to drink
yeah
driving what L Hollywood popular
villains to do Mel Gibson is obviously
an actor and director that I've loved
and supported and wanted him to have a
comeback for a long time now hacks
already even though he's still getting
backlash for the nominators you should
do what everyone knows the problems at
Suicide Squad has even David Ayer even
David a irnos like your the browns with
[ __ ] redic if you're going to get
enough gets to do this you gotta let him
do it r-rated that's the one thing see
Suicide Squad should be our age it's
Deadpool being r-rated and Logan getting
incredible feel like a bunch of reviews
draw everyone is loving Logan everyone
loves this movie it's an RA to flick
everybody but movies can be more than
just pg-13 and for DC going for is
darker vibes but not giving their homes
our ratings let's think about this the
BBS cut is off is r-rated edition and
people like that exceptionally more than
the theatrical version i was pg-13 I
think if you're going to do Suicide
Squad k forgetting and they'll get them
to do it you got to let him do it his
way which is hard our systems are hard
our movie yeah those films are brutal
that he does but what's great about it
he direct action like no one else the
action sequences if you look at like a
pocket listing or even hacksaw rich she
brings action scenes to life in a way
that are realistic yet that are very
stylish their bloody their gory and
they're entertaining and suspenseful and
that something Suicide Squad jizz didn't
have that's just one aspect right there
soon as Squatch did a nap and you could
definitely get that one thing David Ayer
talked about that we thought when we saw
it would like why don't they just make
Joker the main build yeah supernatural
taking down and Contra [ __ ] a bunch of
people with guns yeah but super you been
mad yeah it seems like if you're going
to give melt gifts in the right juice
you got to let him get involved in the
screenplay too because everything he's
ever directed he's involved in the
script processes what I feel like you're
going to have to make the villains more
human whatever the villain is if you're
here to go if you're finally going to do
is to make it the Joker you just have to
make sure that your heroes in your
villains make sense in a fight together
that's me
that's all the Quality Assurance you
need to do there what you brought up is
a good point because that's the only
question mark for me about this
arrangement is like what DC wants to do
is I know the mission statement move
like we're going to make our superhero
films not going to do the Marvel
committee we're going to trust our
creative minds and they've proven that
that is not entirely the case Mel Gibson
Suicide Squad would be a very distinct
film I feel like so well I feel like Mel
Gibson does and he is not afraid of hold
back yeah that's one thing I thought
like why David Ayer might have been a
cool choice for Suicide Squad because
David Ayer notice that I write crime and
grit and yet none of that [ __ ] bigger
being that says what it boggles my mind
about DC is they're good at getting
people where you're like yeah that guy
could totally do that pretty easily just
based on their other work and then it
doesn't work that way and Mel Gibson for
one thing he does really well to its
character driven pieces he knows how to
make great great character and put them
in emotionally builing situations yeah
which is something that suicide squad
needs to be a book called Suicide Squad
you know them guys are going under the
most dangerous missions right now and
that are you're going rogue I feel like
it would be a great chance for Mel
Gibson do this because he recently
talked not a few months ago about how he
thought BBS was [ __ ] and he doesn't like
a lot of these call me pretty much said
BBS oh [ __ ] I think that's exactly what
do you expect yeah you saying a lot of
these movies aren't that great for Mel
Gibson to say that I mean this is a
great chance for him to like see if he's
a man who could live up to the challenge
then for him to be a working director
and kind of call out other directors for
not going all out I feel like Mel Gibson
would have the balls to be brave enough
to just go [ __ ] I'm just going to go
all out with this as long as they let
him do it r rated and go with his grit
in style as much as possible on top of
that too even though make these violent
films he also knows how to bring heart
into it without making it feel to him I
mean hacks el reg is a different case
course is going to feel a little a me
it's about dudes all about Jesus's in
the face Bay yeah it's a faith based
thing but I feel like what Suicide Club
and a date was really honor the
characters this guy is the master at
research if you look at how gifts
themselves what he does for a lot of
historical films he does tons and tons
of historical research before they start
writing this up he wants to make sure he
honor the authenticity of it all so
knowing him he would probably look at
the comic books as a version of history
and they really go into it and try to
honor that as much as possible and then
bringing it to life in a great story
yeah and I mean he's done so many kinds
of movies as an actor I'm sure a lot of
that experience he can draw from the
thing too is like we're in an
interesting time right now because you
know especially even in the wake of just
the most recent DC movies in the wake of
Marvel's last wave of movies you've got
Logan you got Deadpool and like comic
book movie is now at an interesting time
because you know you have all those
people before be like ah you know it's
going to crash it's going to crumble
we're going to hit critical mass and I
don't think that's necessarily a case
and I think what we're learning right
now we're seeing is whether or not the
genre will crash or whether it will
adapt and broaden out and become more
than just you know a pg-13 temple moving
giving something like a suicide squad to
Mel Gibson and again like you said if
you let him take rain over it that could
be an interesting opportunity if it's
played the right way I think it's a
risky choice because mel gibson is not
known to do modern-day flicks like this
so it's a risky choice that yep it's
very out of this rental but I also feel
like Mel gifts to comply bring something
unique for its to be a great chance for
DC and a great chance for milk is in the
show different side yeah and then maybe
make something more of a film and not
just a movie yeah exactly all right guys
what do you think about no gifts and
directing Suicide Squad they need to
channel can subscribe to the real
rejects John's Rita so Jerry on Twitter
and Instagram social media manager of
bloom house and the real rejects and now
it is time for me to urinate